[Musique]
2000 où il est j'y ce bonjour bonjour
monsieur livory vous êtes candidat à
rivière-pilote vous avez 46 ans vous
êtes responsable technique adjoint dans
une dans une entreprise informatique et
vous allez conduire la liste rivière
pilote en actions quelles sont les
raisons pourquoi vous vous présenter je
serais tenté de dire oui pourquoi pas
c'est la démocratie qui le permet
ailleurs ce n'est pas toujours possible
et puis il faut savoir monsieur livory
que je suis impliqué dans ma commune
depuis plus de vingt ans de façon
continuelle à travers la vie la vie
associative et puis j'ai rencontré un
certain nombre de commerçants certain
nombre d'habitants des responsables
d'associations et qui pensent qu'ils
partagent avec moi certain nombre
d'insuffisances sécurité identifiés
alors vous êtes membre de pays à anciens
du mime et vous aller contre le maire
raymond théodose qui a soutenu jean
philippe miller co présidents de pays à
votre candidature est perçu par certains
comme une sorte de trahison
alors vous êtes un petit peu taquin
c'est vrai que je n'ai pas demandé
d'investiture à pia je n'ai pas demandé
de soutien non pluie et je ne suis pas
rester là les bras croisés à attendre
l'autorisation de quiconque
c'est vrai que certains qu'ils
constatent que leur que les intentions
de vote de la population ne se porte pas
forcément sur sur leurs candidatures
s'adonnent à des à de tels propos
mais bon je crois qu'il se trompe et
puis peut-être aussi qu'il pense que je
suis le maire sortant
raymond théodose n'est pas là ni
politique j'ai de l'amitié
il y a une certaine amitié entre raymond
théodose et moi lui ôter aux doses n'ai
pas d'amis politiques gia de l'amitié
entre raymond théodose et et moi mais il
ne s'agit pas de cela
il s'agit de défendre les intérêts de la
commune donc il s'agit pas non plus de
mélanger de l'eau et des épices et dire
qu'on fera une bonne sauce il s'agit pas
non plus de casser des oeufs
et dire qu'on va faire monter la
mayonnaise quatre candidats issus du
mime pour cette élection dans 2020 n'y
en a pas moins de 4 c'est une première
dans la commune le chef n'est plus là il
est parti c'est la démo nat
je ne comprends pas trop votre question
quatre candidats issus du mime
pour nous il y a des choses qui sont
plus importantes que de perdre son temps
à accorder une quelconque importance une
quelconque importance à ce qui n'en vaut
pas la peine
il y un certain nombre de choses qui
nous interpellent je pense j'ai à
l'image un ce restaurateur du marché de
rivière-pilote les larmes aux yeux
décourager démobilisés démoralisé pardon
j'ai également à l'image
7 cet employé qui me disait qu'elle
était inquiète pour son avenir parce que
son son patron en a vraiment mais j'ai
aussi une attention particulière pour la
population parce qu'on parle des
commerçants mais pour la population du
bout également qui attendent des
réponses concrètes à cette situation qui
n'a que trop duré alors la mise hors
d'eau du de la commune sera bien sûr au
centre de toute la campagne
vous avez des propositions c'est pas en
cinq minutes qu'on pourrait étaler les
propositions et j'avais tout tous les
pilotins a participé à
à nos unions de quartier qui rencontre
un vrai succès cependant
moi ce que je dis il ne s'agit pas de
débarquer avec des programmes des
projets que l'on va annoncer à la
population
nous disons qu'il faut associer la
population aux réflexions
rien ne doit se faire sans l'accord de
la population il faut il nous faut
mettre la population au centre des
décisions
alors concernant le problème
d'inondation
je ne pense pas qu'il y à une solution
magique c'est un ensemble de
propositions qui permettront de ce qui
permettra de trouver la solution
ça c'est très important trop souvent
trop souvent l approche des élections il
ya un certain nombre de candidats qui
arrivent avec des projets qui viennent
taper sur les épaules de la population
et puis après les élections et
disparaître
ils disparaissent alors nous nous disons
qu'il faut divorcer avec cette façon de
faire dès notre arrivée dès notre
arrivée nous allons associer la
population à la réflexion concernant le
développement durable de la commune qu
elle l axe principal
il nous reste 30 secondes de votre
programme
tout est à refaire au joli dit il y à un
certain nombre de points sur lesquels
nous avons posé le curseur cette
jeunesse abandonnée et ben à cette
jeunesse nous allons leur dire que dès
notre arrivée nous allons passer une
convention avec un cabinet conseil
de sorte qu'à chaque fois qu'ils seront
porteurs d'un projet nous pouvons les
aiguiller vers ce cabinet conseil et qui
les accompagnera qu'ils accompagneront
de sorte que ccc projet puisse voir le
jour
donnez-lui legis je vous remercie
merci monsieur von
[Musique]